well thank you addy for the introduction
so like you said I want to talk to you
about JavaScript tools today and
specifically how you can use type
information to help scale your code base
because as you add more lines of code
and more developers to it there's
certain areas where it becomes harder to
maintain and harder to keep evolving and
changing your card base so my name is
Mark I'm a software engineer at Google
and this is the number of lines of
JavaScript code at Google since 2009 and
it's up and to the right and growing at
a pretty fast pace we we are adding the
size of our code base at 2010 multiple
times a year now and the number of
developers are also growing at that same
little bit frightening pace and with
this we have one single large code base
at Google I know a lot of developers and
so you know at some point this this
becomes harder to maintain it becomes
harder to change your code base and keep
a high quality bar and so myself and a
few other collaborators at Google we we
spent some time trying to figure out
what can we do to help alleviate this
problem what can we do to make it easier
to keep growing the code base so one
example challenge of something that's
hard to do is if you just wanted to
rename a function right it's just you
have a class and you define the function
on it has a very generic name to it why
it's because you're Curtis is so large
you have 50 other classes that have that
exact same name you know how do you
actually differentiate between even
piece of code differentiate between two
objects of different types when you just
want to rename one of those functions
but not the other one and this among and
other problems that arise we to help fix
these we worked on two tools
specifically so the first one is called
re faster j/s and so tool to make
refactoring easy so all the X
is that a developer can come up with for
why it's hard to change a piece of goat
like there's too many people depending
on it it's impossible to fix all those
code to change it this tool should make
all those go away and the second thing
is we call J's conformance which is a
way to prevent bad code from creeping
back into your code base this is a tool
that really helps developers and your
your project keep a very high code
quality bar because no matter who is
reviewing or submitting the code you can
make sure to prevent bad code from
entering your code base and to tie
everything together I want to use a
running example which is really
important to web apps today which is how
do you eliminate XSS issues in your
project so a nexus s can be really
costly to the user losing you to data
enter your company with lawsuits breach
of user privacy and so forth and so
using me faster jazz and show how you
can fix existing bad xss vulnerabilities
and how J's conformers can prevent them
from coming back again into your code
base and so this example is actually
based on something that the security
team at Google has worked on over the
last year which is something they call a
AP I hardening inside Google but
specific to the web it's they worked on
a library called Google safe which is um
safe wrappers around the Dom API the Dom
API has a lot of security holes a lot of
people know about common ones like inner
HTML not sanitizing the HTML that you
pass to it outer HTML eval and a
lesser-known one but still equally
important is if you're assigned to the
href of window dot location and the
import is user control they can actually
execute arbitrary JavaScript code and if
they're evil they can execute code that
steals user data and so forth and so
with a very very tiny change that anyone
could implement you can rewrite that to
use a safe set location HR function and
this would sanitize the input so that no
attack is actually executed a colleague
of mine on the security team actually
published an article in ACM about this
that goes into
more detail about the overall effort and
the other api's so it's definitely a
very interesting read so to dive in the
first tool that I want to talk about is
reef a stooge is and this is a tool
where you write JavaScript to refactor
javascript world JavaScript developers
and we shouldn't have to write another
language or learn something new to try
to change a piece of code we should be
able to write what we want the code to
look like and then something should make
that happen and core additional tenant
is that it leverages type information to
pinpoint the the code that you want to
change so that it's not matching too
much not matching too little but
matching just the piece of code that you
want and we run this at Google over
across with Google's entire JavaScript
code base and so it was designed from
the beginning to make sure to run in
just a matter of minutes across large
sets of code and the core piece of thing
that you need to provide to be faster
jess is just a javascript file and it
looks a little bit like this and there's
two functions that you provide to the
reef astra jazz tool if you notice this
follows these tools are based on the
closure compiler which is an open source
JavaScript compiler from google which
the the main thing that's known for an
open source community is the ability to
process type information and store it
and use at a later time to do type
checking and type based optimizations
and so if you're familiar with that
you're familiar with the type annotation
syntax which provides the compiler what
type these objects are but the first
half of the template shows how what code
should be matched and so this is really
the finding algorithm so that if you
pass a hundred source files it nodes
which specific statements are the ones
that you want to target and the second
thing is then once you have those
matches how do you apply a fix how do
you transform the code what should it
look like in this case we want to match
any direct assignments to location.href
and transform it to use the google safe
library and so look
at the matching code it looks a little
bit like this and this will match the
direct assignment where you have the
left hand side window dot location by
HIV equals some string but also it will
match if you Elias the window location
object to a local variable and still
assign the HRF property of that and on
the right hand side you have a function
that returns a string it still knows how
to match that but it won't match if you
just have an object literal where you're
assigning to an HR I've property of the
object literal because that's not of the
correct type and so this is where the
type information comes into play because
it knows how to differentiate between
all these use cases so how does it do
this well the first thing it needs to do
is build an ast which is a knapsack
abstract syntax tree without going into
too much detail it's just how does the
compiler represent a piece of code and
as you see here on the left hand side is
kind of the node structure of AST so you
see there's an assignment the equal sign
and then there's a left-hand side which
is accessing a property and the right
hand side which is just referencing a
variable and on the right-hand side of
the side you can see it highlighted that
there is this a state preserves type
information whereas a lot of other ahts
for javascript don't preserve this
information because they don't know how
to to infer the type information for
piece of code and so looking at a quick
demo there's this there's a web service
tool where we can look on that that the
compiler team provides where we can
store a piece of code here zooming is
not working super well and then on the
right hand side when we compile this we
can see what the AST looks like and this
is exactly the same as what you see on
the slides in this case we also have the
variable declarations for accessing
storing the URL and the location object
into local variable
and you see here it knows the type
information every single point in this
AST whether it's a string a window
object or a location object and that's a
nifty tool if you just want to play
around and see what the closure compiler
is doing and and see how it impacts what
the AST looks like and what the types
look like once you have this then the
tool needs to compare ASC structures
against from the template against the
source code there's a lot of different
ways to do this depending on you know
the accuracy of the matches and what you
have available to it so the first
approach kind of a naive approach is to
just match what the node structure looks
like and in this case you just take the
left hand side which is kind of the
structure of the code and make sure that
those match and notice Lee if you change
one node in it say you change it from a
variable to a string literal then it
won't match anymore and so this will
match things like location href equals a
URL it will also match some random
object where you reference a name
property and some string because as the
same structure even though the types and
the names of the objects are different
and also unfortunately it won't match
something like location that href equals
R string literal because that they have
different structures and so you can
improve this a little bit you can use
the node structure and the name of the
variables but again if you do that then
changing one of the two whether it's the
structure or the variable name causes it
to break and so this will match you know
if you alias LOC window down location to
the LOC variable it will match that but
it will also match it if you just have a
normal object literal and it won't match
another case where you change the
variable name so this is still not
really what we want because it's not
accurate enough and that's where the
reef a stage as we get to this last
matching which is it uses either the
node name and structure or the
JavaScript type this is where the type
comes in handy to be able to have the
flexibility to match different different
pieces of code and so every level
this AST you can see it's either
matching on one side the left hand side
or the right hand side but doesn't have
to to match both and the way it knows
whether it neat which one it needs to
match is you told it in the template you
told it which are the types which are
the wild card types and which you
actually have to be the exact same thing
like the hrf property has to be href and
so here you see that the the boxes
correspond these a sts are different but
they resolve to the same type and this
is okay this is what we fasted jeaious
matches against and so with this we get
matching the alias case where we have i
will seed ihr f equal 0 or we have the
full thing window dot location da href
equals some function call and we also
don't get if you just have an object
that it will and sign a property on that
because it's all the different types so
this is looking pretty good this is this
is will match the right set of code once
we have that then we need to take this
code and transform it to what the code
we want it to look like and so it looks
this function looks very similar to the
before case the matching case except the
body of the function corresponds to what
you want the code to look like in this
case we just want it to look use the set
location href function and so it will
take an example like the top piece of
code and then transform it to something
like the bottom piece of code where it
preserves the names and curd structure
because the tool doesn't care about any
of that so you can alias windowed
allocation to whatever name you feel
like and it would still preserve the
right piece of code and it does this
because of this matching by type it
knows that in the template it the loc
variable should be replaced by the
source code that it matched against from
the same type and so it can preserve
that code structure and names and so so
taking a look at a demo back to the
handy web service page we can see
down here that the template you can
enter in this page the template exactly
as it looks on the slide so this is
exactly the same as what i had on the
slides including matching the direct
assignment and transforming it to goog
down safe and then you can see up top
that I've input a lot of sample code
following different JavaScript contracts
that you might have in a real code base
whether it's a direct assignment whether
you're a leasing local variables whether
you're assigning it the functions
whatever it may be and then when I hit
this button and run I can then see what
the tool would transform the code to
look like and so here can zoom in a
little bit here I can see that it
transformed each of the statements on
the left-hand side that we want to the
corresponding goop Dom save sub-location
hrf function preserving the code
structure whether it's using a string a
variable name a function call or even
accepting function parameters and
preserving that as well but again
because it knows understands type
information it doesn't match when you
just have some something that's not of
type location like an object literal and
so this is a pretty handy tool because
it can also show you how you can debug
this if you have closure compiler
warnings in the code say you know the
code is in formatted correctly or it
doesn't know certain types and it also
shows you at the bottom the ast s of
both the template and the source code
and so if something's not looking
correctly you can compare these against
each other and see that whether they
should or should not match based on the
type information and the node names so
like I said this was designed to run
across large code bases and if your code
is large enough where it's prohibitive
to run it sequentially across resource
files you can run it as part of a
MapReduce which we do at Google and in a
matter of seconds or minutes run it
across hundreds thousands tens of
thousands
millions of files in just a very short
amount of time in addition to fixing xss
vulnerabilities which is a very
important thing to do for your project
another use case is how can you keep
evolving your code base and so as your
code grows more and more people are
depending on core libraries and AP is
and becomes harder and harder to change
these you know if you wrote a piece of
code five years ago it may be carefully
you may want to change the type
signature you may want to change how
people use it you may want to migrate
them to something else and it just
becomes harder and harder and so this
the refi cgi's tool can be used to make
sure that all the excuses engineers have
for not modifying an updating code are
eliminated and they can refactor api's
and constantly evolve the code basin and
holding it to the highest quality
standard and making sure that the api's
r is robust and as nice to use as
possible this is this is how we refactor
the core libraries inside of Google for
JavaScript it's tremendously useful so a
common question that burns on people's
mind is well I don't use type
information is this is this of any use
to be and there's good and bad news with
this yes it can be useful but at the
same time the compiler might not have
all the information that it needs and so
you may get unexpected results and so
opening opening this demo you can see on
this right-hand side I have a function
where I take an anchor element and sign
the HR property of that to some URL all
right and so in the specific example
that I gave before this shouldn't match
because you have an anchor tag and not a
location element or a location object
but unfortunately because there's no
type information here we fast jazz does
transform this and so you get a lot of
false positives in this case the good
news is that the closure compiler team
does a lot of work trying to improve
type inference and they're working on it
all the time and they have a major
change that's coming out over the next
months which will actually keep
improving how much type information
communion furred so the compiler runs a
series of passes that take information
already knows like how do you call a
function what variables you like how do
you construct object and then tries to
infer the rest of your coat the types of
the rest of your code so that you don't
have to explicitly type it and so you
know constantly trying to improve this
the reef ash DJ is to land the closure
compiler itself can become more and more
useful for projects that don't use type
annotations so now that you fix the
existing usages in your code you want to
make sure that people don't introduce
new ones right because every new one
would be a new xss vulnerability and
something that your project you don't
want to be submitted into your project
and so it's as your project grows and as
your company grows it's not really
feasible to make sure that someone keeps
an eye of all the code being checked in
your code base and using the J's
conformance framework you can help make
sure that becomes programmatic and
automatic as part of your builder
compile step so that they never get
submitted in the first place so with a
few lines of code that you pass as a
configuration object to the closure
compiler you can prevent this from ever
from from this direct assignment of
location.href ever coming back and the
user would get a nice compiler error
saying this is not allowed this is a
violation that you're not allowed
allowed to directly assigned to
location.href but use goog Dom safe
instead and so with this then the
developer knows that they have to go
back and fix the code and you've avoided
the check again the XS s whole to begin
with or whether it's something else that
you want if it's if you're refactoring
api's or so forth so breaking down this
configuration the first thing that you
want to provide to it is the type of the
conformance and here we're using a
banned property right which means that
we want to ban
people from directly assigning to a
specific property but there's a lot of
other different conformance types that
the compiler provides and each one is
meant to target a specific idiom that
JavaScript developers use every day
whether it's referencing a property
writing or reading a property calling a
function or and so forth and so as
another example you can bend eval just
by saying band name and specifying eval
as the value more complicated you can
use the reef assage as syntax to provide
a much more flexible configuration for
the compiler that matches more complex
code statements and so if there's
something more something more
complicated than just banning a property
or a function call then you can use this
syntax exactly the same as we fast to
jas to create the conformance
configuration as well the second thing
you need to do is just provide which
value you want to ban and so this
depends on the type in this case because
we're banning property rights we want to
ban anything that's assigning to
location prototype hf but it can be any
object or any property name that you
want in the in your entire code base
third you want to provide a nice error
message so this is what developers would
see when they get a violation and you
want it to be both informative and
telling the developer why it's not
allowed and also what they can use
instead so that when they see this they
go okay I just have to go back make a
quick change change it to use goog done
safe instead and lastly you can also use
a whitelist and this is say if you have
an approved usage of the code this
directory has been approved by the
security team because it's been heavily
audited then this director you won't or
this file won't be warned upon when the
compiler checks the code so going back
to the Handy debugger page that we were
earlier
there's a box here if you want to try
this out that contains the the
conformance configuration so here you
can see that this configuration is
exactly the same as what you saw on the
slides earlier and then you can again go
up to this box here and insert some
JavaScript and whatever you want to test
when you hit compile you can see here
that the compiler in this warning box
shows you the violation if i change the
piece of code to say again you know i
want to change the type all right so if
I alias windows location to local
variable and hit recompile just like
refresh to jazz it knows the code
structure and the type information that
knows that this statement is still not
allowed even if you a Leah sloka
variables call a function you know do
whatever magic you want the compiler
because they understands type of
information is able to warn and only
worn on the cases where it's actually a
violation
so just like we faster jess is a number
of other possibilities that you can do
this tool it's very similar to a lot
that you can do would say es Lin but
because it knows type of information you
can take it one step further and start
banging more different different
problems that you find in your code base
such as banning all these xss
vulnerabilities including you noe valley
innerhtml outer HTML document right
location by href and so forth you can
also use it as part of a core libraries
team to say restrict deprecated API
calls if you're trying to migrate your
code base from one API to another API
then you want to prevent people from
using the old one as you migrate and so
one instance if you want to migrate your
code base to promises then banning your
old async primitive like deferred or
whatever else it might be would be a
very use would be a good use of the J's
form its framework and last you can also
specify any team or project specific
concerns that you have because the
framework is flexible so all of these
tools are now available open source on
the closure compiler github page and I
hope that they owe computers little
freaking out
ok so these tools are available open
source all of the debugging pages I
showed are available online also and so
you can use them to take a look at all
the tools and see whether they may be
useful but I hope that by you know
trying to utilize type information that
you can take I'm just gonna there we go
that you can try to take your codebase
one step further and make sure that it
scales as it grows where the number of
developers in the number of lines of
code to make sure that you can keep it
the most secure performant and highest
quality quality code base that you can
and so please take a look and please
provide feedback definitely interested
in hearing how it can be used externally
thank you